pour commenter ces informations de
première importance j'accueille
maintenant le professeur mendy khadr
comme des c'est un médecin pédiatre il
était spécialiste des fièvres
hémorragiques à l'organisation mondiale
de la santé jusqu'en 2012 et il est
aujourd'hui président de la fondation
santé et développement durable façade
monsieur comme des docteurs qui ont des
bons jours en pension il ya beaucoup de
choses dont on peut parler effectivement
commençons par cet investissement qui
vient d'être annoncée par la ministre
canadienne de la santé madame humbles
aux 30 millions de dollars qui vont
s'ajouter 1 et 35 millions de dollars
qui a déjà été investi par le
gouvernement du canada dire que le
gouvernement canadien est ce que dans
les circonstances ça vous semble
une contribution correct pour le canada
non je pense que c'est quelque chose de
correct important mais il faut seulement
s'assurer que ce qui est annoncé arrive
sur le terrain parce qu'il ya souvent un
décalage entre ce qui est annoncé et ça
c'est un peu logique de la communication
actuels même au village ma grammaire
aussi sur tout ce qu'on dit et après le
personnel après les allégeant qui
travaillent sur le terrain ne reçoivent
pas en temps réel toutes ces mots tous
ces montants annoncés
je crois que c'est une très bonne chose
et aussi montrer que le canada par
rapport à la guinée a été très présente
en appui au programme contes lutte
contre le sida
je me rappelle encore avec l'université
de montréal pour renforcer les capacités
mais cette intervention est très timide
aujourd'hui et je pense que l'eau bella
doit pouvoir ouvrir les portes pour
renforcer la collaboration
mais l'intervention de la communauté
internationale restent très timides de
façon générale c'est exactement ce que
nous dit aujourd'hui le président de la
banque mondiale qui créent même quand on
est en train de perdre le combat
actuellement parce que cette solidarité
n'est pas suffisamment importante elle
est importante en termes de volonté
maintenant comment traduire toute cette
volonté en termes d'action concrète sur
le terrain c'est ça tout le défi et je
pense que cette épidémie
c'est quelque chose de nouveau autant
pour l'afrique occidentale
autant pour les communautés ça je pense
qu'il faut qu'au soir
mais quand vous dites que ces nouveaux
est-ce qu'on a pas de jeu combattu les
ball en 95-96 au congo dont moi j'ai eu
la chance j'étais à tiques 8c saberi
pour les mollahs au temps de jeu travers
l oms on a fait un travail qui a eu des
résultats significativement important
mais la différence entre l'afrique
centrale et l'afrique de l'ouest elle en
termes de communication de mouvements de
personnel donc d'activités
transfrontalières
il n'y a pas souvent de route dans la
forêt congolaise pour de tic 8 à
kinshasa
longue de 600 km en faisait 3 1 et 3
jours dont alors que 24 heures vous
casser de bamako à conakry ou de vous
quitter bamako à ouagadougou
le trafic est plus intense les
mouvements sont plus importants et les
communications interpersonnelles des
choses sont très très importants et qui
donne une nouvelle dimension à
l'épidémie la maladie est la même c'est
le même ennemi hausse avait à ce moment
là comment le combattre non oui on a les
mesures de contrôle classique il faut
prendre en charge les malades
il faut faire une système de
surveillance en place il faut sur les
contacts
il faut enterrer de façon sécurisée
comme on le disait les cadavres de faire
une bonne communication mais en a raté
la communication aussi de façon générale
quand je dit aux gens n'y a pas de
médicaments il n'y a pas de vaccin et a
pas de il n'y a pas de traitement
et après on vous dit d'aller dans les
formations sanitaires et contre comme
heures parce que l'épidémie d'ebola elle
est très pâle et très mortelle a
finalement les gens ne fréquente pas
donc tous ces aspects doivent être
renforcés avec vous les pressions leurs
vues d'ici qu'on a mal géré la crise dès
les premiers moments sur le terrain dans
les pros pays qui sont les plus touchées
par la maladie
j'aiderai parc on a mal géré mer on a
peut-être sous-estimé parce qu'on ne
savait pas que c'était une maladie aussi
foudroyant aussi grave qui pouvait avoir
des conséquences énormes on passait
peut-être que le hezbollah c'est comme
une crise de palu ou le monde
autrement ce qui n'est pas le cas mais
je sais que il y a eu d'épidémie de face
par exemple où la communauté
internationale a été confronté et on a
pu quand même la juguler mais vu dans la
perspective de nos pays nous avons un
des systèmes de santé faible si
aujourd'hui un cas survient au canada
j'ai eu des contacts avec le laboratoire
de santé publique et la madame tremblay
et puis l' agence de choses mais on a vu
que quand même le système de santé est
telle qu'on peut prendre en main
rapidement et je voudrais vous entendre
aussi sur ce que dit aujourd'hui
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
reconnaît qu'il ya eu des lacunes dans
la façon dont elle est intervenu là bas
problème d'incompétence du personnel
c'est quand même assez grave comme comme
accusation manque d'information
également d'informations vous y avez
fait référence déjà
est ce que le personnel est compétent
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
je ne dirais pas un terme de compétences
parce que quand vous êtes dans des
conditions difficiles comme la guinée
parfois sans eau sans électricité les
éléments de base de l'hygiène de base
manquent que le système est faible même
si vous prenez les plus personne n'est
plus compétent dans un système de santé
fait vous vous allez être médias pour
faible aussi des ça le contexte est
important il faut tenir compte de cela
retournons nous pour conclure cette
entrevue sur l'avenir qu'est ce qui doit
être fait a compté mais je pense qu'il
faut mettre tout en å
et j'étais dans la réunion de genève
récemment du 29 au 30 où l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a organisé une
réunion pour les essais cliniques sur
les médicaments et les vaccins
je pense qu'il faut mettre beaucoup
d'accent sur ça il faut renforcer la
surveillance des maladies et puis
renforcer les capacités de nos systèmes
de santé
c'est bien qu'on vienne nous aider mais
il faut nous apprendre à pêcher et je
crois que c'est un élément extrêmement
important dans le renforcement de
capacités j'étais avec l'université de
montréal l'unité de santé publique
il ya beaucoup de choses qui peut être
fait sur le terrain concrètement tout en
renforçant les capacités très bien
d'acteurs comme des merci beaucoup
l'abriter des nôtres c'est moi bonne
journée